Vibe coding is a thing, rage coding is a thing, but there's this sweet spot right in the middle. I call it guide coding. It's where you're basically, you're pair programming with an AI, you're not driving, the AI is driving and you just hold its hand. Sometimes it's just hitting home run after home run after home run and then every once in a while it'll do something stupid. I want to use a unit testing framework that isn't going to light up my Clang tidy like a Christmas tree. So I asked it what the alternatives were and it recommended a few But really I wanted to try out Chris use the X boost
“氛围编程”是一种现象，“愤怒编程”也是一种现象，但在这两者之间有一个最佳平衡点。我称之为“引导式编程”。在这种模式下，你基本上是在与人工智能进行结对编程，你不是驾驶员，AI 才是，你只需要牵着它的手。有时它能接连不断地打出全垒打，但偶尔它也会犯傻。我想使用一个不会让我的 Clang-Tidy 像圣诞树一样亮起红灯的单元测试框架。所以我问它有哪些替代方案，它推荐了几个，但我真正想尝试的是 Chris Yusiak 的 Boost.UT。
Extended UT and sure enough five minutes or so later It made changes to my CMake list.txt file and then one by one just went and changed all 1700 lines of code. Welcome to ADSB the podcast episode 233 recorded on May 7th, 2025. My name is Connor and today I record solo live from the Las Palmas Park in Sunnyvale. I chat about Cursor, Clot 3.7, Gemini 2.5 Pro and a recent amazing success that I had with these tools. We, or should I say I are recording today from Las Palmas Park because when I arrived here a couple days ago I was able to get a lifer, which in burger parlance is what you call a bird
Extended UT，果然五分钟左右，它修改了我的 CMakeLists.txt 文件，然后一行一行地把 1700 行代码全部改完了。欢迎收听 ADSB 播客第 233 期，录制于 2025 年 5 月 7 日。我是 Connor，今天我独自在桑尼维尔的拉斯帕尔马斯公园进行现场录制。我将聊聊 Cursor、Claude 3.7、Gemini 2.5 Pro，以及我最近利用这些工具取得的一项惊人成就。我们，或者说我，今天是在拉斯帕尔马斯公园录音，因为几天前我刚到这里时，我成功“打鸟”了，在观鸟术语中，这就是指你第一次看到的鸟。
you've seen for the first time and it was the... actually don't know how to pronounce this. I looked it up and couldn't find a video of anyone pronouncing this bird's name either Mitred or Mitred Parakeet or Conyer and it said it was a rare bird and they were up in the palm trees in this park but they are no longer here and I was hoping to get a very nice background noise because they were making the noises that we'll call the my tread parakeets make. But alas, we are back on my last full day in Sunnyvale and this is a solo episode.
你第一次见到它，它就是……其实我不知道怎么发音。我查了一下，也没找到任何关于这个鸟名发音的视频，是叫 Mitred Parakeet（红额鹦哥）还是 Conure（锥尾鹦哥）。资料说这是一种稀有鸟类，它们曾出现在这个公园的棕榈树上，但现在已经不在了。我本来希望能录到非常好的背景噪音，因为它们发出的声音就是我们所说的红额鹦哥的叫声。但可惜，现在是我在桑尼维尔的最后一个完整日，这是一期单人节目。
First ever solo episode, I think? I could be wrong about that. I believe it's episode 233 we're gonna title this one AI live from Sunnyvale which is a callback to episode 232 which I recorded with Bryce now almost a month ago although you listened to it last week which was entitled algorithms live from New York we might not get any parakeets in the background, but you probably have heard the American crows. Nothing special about those birds,
这是有史以来第一次单人节目吧？我可能记错了。我相信这是第 233 期，我们打算把这一期命名为“AI 桑尼维尔现场”，这是对第 232 期的呼应，那期是我大约一个月前和 Bryce 录制的，虽然你们上周才听到，标题是“算法纽约现场”。我们可能录不到背景里的鹦哥叫声，但你们可能听到了美洲乌鸦的声音。这些鸟没什么特别的，
although they are very intelligent. Anyways, I've got my Merlin app on, and if any bird sounds pop up, I will report. But in the meantime, I am going to give a short solo episode on my massive successes with AI, GenAI specifically. I am pretty sure that I've mentioned on the podcast, but if I haven't, I've been using cursor for several months now, but have been relying on it significantly in the last month or two. And I would say my productivity has 10x to 100x.
尽管它们非常聪明。总之，我打开了 Merlin 应用，如果有任何鸟叫声出现，我会报告。但在此期间，我将简短地录制一期单人节目，分享我在 AI，特别是生成式 AI 方面取得的巨大成功。我很确定我在播客里提到过，但如果没提过的话，我已经使用 Cursor 好几个月了，但在过去一两个月里非常依赖它。我会说我的生产力提高了 10 倍到 100 倍。
Yes, there are some things that AI is not good at, but there are other things that it's absolutely phenomenal at. And I've told this anecdotal story to several folks, including Bryce, over the last week or so. And I thought I'd share it with you here. Why am I not interviewing someone? I did mean to reach out to Ben last week to set something up, but waited a little bit too long, and also too. I'm down here in the States from Monday until tomorrow, Thursday, and I have to edit this basically before Thursday.
是的，有些事情 AI 不擅长，但有些事情它做得非常出色。过去一周左右，我向包括 Bryce 在内的几个人讲过这个轶事。我想在这里也和大家分享一下。为什么我没有采访别人？我本来打算上周联系 Ben 安排一下，但拖得太久了，而且我也从周一到周四都在美国，我基本上必须在周四之前完成这期的剪辑。
And I could have grabbed someone from NVIDIA to chat with, but it's basically been an internal conference and I am absolutely exhausted and what I really wanted to just do was come back to this park and get the parakeets in the background and chat about AI. But like I said no parakeets, only AI and crows I guess. And so I've been using Cursor. For those of you that don't know, Cursor is one of the AI-assisted IDE's. It's a fork of VS Code. Alternatives to this are Winsurf. I think technically you can hook up Copilot to VS Code as well. And it's got a couple different modes, Agentic mode, Ask mode. There's one other mode that I never use.
我本可以找个 NVIDIA 的人来聊聊，但最近基本上都是内部会议，我实在太累了，我真正想做的就是回到这个公园，录下背景里的鹦哥叫声，聊聊 AI。但就像我说的，没有鹦哥，只有 AI 和乌鸦。所以我一直在用 Cursor。对于那些不知道的人，Cursor 是 AI 辅助 IDE 之一。它是 VS Code 的一个分支。替代品还有 Windsurf。我想技术上你也可以把 Copilot 连接到 VS Code。它有几种不同的模式，Agentic（智能体）模式、Ask（询问）模式。还有一种我从不使用的模式。
And you can select the LLM that you want to use. So I only switch between Claude 3.7 and Gemini 2.5 Pro. I find that Claude 3.7 is the best in general, but if you need some larger task, sometimes Claude 3.7 fails at and the task that I'm going to tell you it did fail at, but Gemini 2.5 Pro absolutely crushed it on this. And the task was basically switching my test framework, so the library that I'm working on I was using Google test with, I had roughly 1700 lines of code, roughly 150 tests, and within those tests 350 plus asserts.
你可以选择你想使用的 LLM。我只在 Claude 3.7 和 Gemini 2.5 Pro 之间切换。我发现 Claude 3.7 在大多数情况下是最好的，但如果你有更大的任务，有时 Claude 3.7 会失败，而我接下来要说的那个任务它确实失败了，但 Gemini 2.5 Pro 在这方面表现得非常出色。这个任务基本上是切换我的测试框架，因为我正在处理的库使用的是 Google Test，我有大约 1700 行代码，大约 150 个测试，在这些测试中有 350 多个断言。
So not, you know, 10,000 lines of unit tests, but still, you know, close to 2,000 lines of code to switch, you know, test frameworks is not something I would ever even really consider doing. The reason that I wanted to switch from Google test is that I used cursor and cloud 3.7 basically to set up ClangTidy and slowly turn on basically all of the linting rules. And Google test does not work well with these linting rules. And if you ask the AI what you should do, it basically recommends that you set up two different Clang-Tidy files with two different sets
所以，并不是说有 1 万行单元测试，但即便如此，要切换近 2000 行代码的测试框架，也不是我平时会考虑去做的事情。我之所以想从 Google Test 切换出来，是因为我使用 Cursor 和 Claude 3.7 设置了 Clang-Tidy，并慢慢开启了几乎所有的代码检查规则。而 Google Test 在这些检查规则下表现并不好。如果你问 AI 该怎么做，它通常会建议你设置两个不同的 Clang-Tidy 文件，使用两套不同的
of linting rules. And you have basically a less strict set of linting rules for your unit tests. And I didn't want to do that. The alternative is commenting no lint on every single test that has an error, which is basically all of them. But I basically didn't want to do that. I want to use a unit testing framework
检查规则。这样你的单元测试就可以使用一套不那么严格的检查规则。但我不想那样做。另一种选择是给每一个有错误的测试都加上“no lint”注释，这基本上意味着所有的测试都要加。但我不想那样做。我想使用一个单元测试框架
that isn't gonna light up my ClangTidy like a Christmas tree. So I asked it what the alternatives were and it recommended a few, but really I wanted to try out Chris Yusiak's Boost Extended UT because I had seen it either in a lightning talk or a C++ talk from a number of years ago and I know it was super modern, and I was pretty sure that it had all the fancy bells and whistles and clang format, clang tidy, et cetera. And I attempted basically to tell Cloud 3.7, I want you to update my CMake list.txt from Google Test
它不会让我的 Clang-Tidy 像圣诞树一样亮起红灯。所以我问它有哪些替代方案，它推荐了几个，但我真正想尝试的是 Chris Yusiak 的 Boost.UT，因为我几年前在闪电演讲或 C++ 会议上看到过它，我知道它非常现代，而且我确信它拥有所有花哨的功能，支持 Clang-Format、Clang-Tidy 等等。我尝试告诉 Claude 3.7，我想把你从 Google Test 更新到 Boost.UT，然后移植我所有的测试，Claude 3.7 会忙活一会儿，然后它会转换大约 10% 的测试文件，剩下的 90% 直接丢弃。所以这是一次彻底的失败，但就像我说的，当 Claude 3.7 失败或者任何 LLM 失败时，你只需要换一个试试。Gemini 2.5，它会转圈三到五分钟，甚至问我是否要强制退出 Cursor，因为它以为程序卡死了。
to Boost Extended UT, and then just port all my tests and Cloud 3.7 would churn for a little bit and Then it would convert, you know, 10% of my test file and discard the other 90% So epic failure, but like I said when cloud 3.7 fails or when any of the LLMs fail You just go try another one. Gemini 2.5, it would spin from anywhere from three to five minutes to the point where actually it was asking me if I wanted to force quit cursor because it thought it had frozen.
但我只是说了几次“等待”，果然，五分钟左右后，它修改了我的 CMakeLists.txt 文件，然后一行一行地开始转换。
But I just said wait a couple times, and sure enough, five minutes or so later, it made changes to my CMake list.txt file and then one by one just went brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr library because I used thrust pair in this library and for some reason it was saying that the Ostream less than less than operator wasn't defined for thrust pair and even when I defined it, it was still whining about a bunch of stuff. So I spent 45 minutes trying to fix this and then gave up. And so then I went and tried two different libraries.
因为我在这个库中使用了 thrust::pair，出于某种原因，它说 thrust::pair 没有定义 Ostream 的“<<”运算符，即使我定义了它，它还是在抱怨一堆东西。所以我花了 45 分钟试图修复这个问题，然后放弃了。于是我尝试了另外两个库。
And actually before I tried Chris Yusehik's UT library, I went and tried two different libraries. And actually before I tried Chris Yusiak's UT library, I actually accidentally tried another one which was called like minunittest, which is a C unit testing framework. It unfortunately uses the UT name that Chris Yusiak's library uses as well. So that was a mistake. I wasted 20 minutes testing out, you know, a different unit testing framework library because I wasn't I Wasn't paying close enough attention which is bound to happen. We do have a bird here. That is a That is flying
其实在尝试 Chris Yusiak 的 UT 库之前，我试了两个不同的库。实际上，在尝试 Chris Yusiak 的 UT 库之前，我不小心试了另一个叫 minunittest 的库，这是一个 C 语言单元测试框架。不幸的是，它也使用了 Chris Yusiak 库所用的 UT 这个名字。所以那是个错误。我浪费了 20 分钟去测试一个不同的单元测试框架，因为我没有足够仔细，这种事难免会发生。我们这里有一只鸟，正在飞
Closer to me. It's not making any noise could be an American Robin look at that we got a Canada goose at the other side of this pool and Might have been an American Robin. Anyways, I accidentally tested the C unit testing framework, discarded that, went back to Google test, then tried out the one I wanted to, Boost Extended UT. That one didn't work. And then I went to Doctest. And Doctest got it up and running in like five to 10 minutes.
靠近我。它没发出任何声音，可能是只美洲知更鸟。看，水池那边有只加拿大雁，刚才那只可能是美洲知更鸟。总之，我不小心测试了那个 C 语言单元测试框架，放弃了它，回到 Google Test，然后尝试了我想要的 Boost.UT。那个没成功。然后我转用了 Doctest。Doctest 在五到十分钟内就搞定了。
All the tests converted and it worked great. There was I think one lint that it was whining about which was some no discard. And that was only because basically I had cleared out and so I don't even think that was an issue with Doctest but anyways within a couple extra I had to no lint a couple things. It was working perfectly.
所有的测试都转换完成了，运行得很好。我想只有一处代码检查在抱怨，是关于“no discard”的。那只是因为我清理了代码，所以我认为那甚至不是 Doctest 的问题，但无论如何，我只需要给几处地方加上“no lint”。它运行得非常完美。
And basically, in less than three hours or so, I had tested out three different C++ slash C unit testing frameworks. And if your mind is not blown by this, this is not something that I would have ever considered trying to do, because it's just too much work like to port a couple thousand lines of code one by one and it's such mundane work and figuring out the mapping from the macros in one library
基本上，在不到三个小时的时间里，我测试了三个不同的 C++/C 单元测试框架。如果这还没让你感到震惊，那是因为这根本不是我会考虑去做的事情，因为移植几千行代码的工作量太大了，而且是非常琐碎的工作，还要搞清楚一个库的宏到另一个库的映射，
to another library it's just a headache and you're not going to do it and now you have this tool and it's able to do these kinds of things for you. Anyways, absolutely thrilled. I'm now using Doctest. I think it actually compiles a little bit faster than Google Test as well. And it's phenomenal. So cursor, I highly recommend you try it out.
这简直让人头疼，你根本不会去做。但现在有了这个工具，它能为你完成这些事情。总之，我非常激动。我现在正在使用 Doctest。我觉得它的编译速度实际上比 Google Test 还要快一点。它太棒了。所以，我强烈推荐你们试试 Cursor。
Like I said, I hear a lot of folks, they say, oh, I tried this thing and it works terribly. I've run into cases where, you know, I put cursor and Cloud 3.7 in agentic mode and give it the ability to, you know, run commands, I don't have to approve everything, and I'll say, you know, run the tests, look at building.md on how to run tests and how to build, and, you know, make changes, if you hit a compilation error a compilation error, fix it and just basically spin until you get this to work.
就像我说的，我听到很多人说，哦，我试了这个东西，效果很差。我遇到过这种情况，我把 Cursor 和 Claude 3.7 设置为智能体模式，让它有权运行命令，我不必批准每一项操作，我会说，运行测试，查看 building.md 了解如何运行测试和构建，如果遇到编译错误，修复它，基本上就是一直运行直到成功。
And after a couple minutes, it'll decide that the best way to solve this problem is by deleting the tests and the corresponding code. So it is far from perfect. Sometimes you've got to smash the AI a little bit over the head. And I meant to mention this at the beginning. People talk about vibe coding, which is where you don't check the code. There's another version called rage coding in my opinion, which is when the AI starts gaslighting you
几分钟后，它会认为解决这个问题的最好方法是删除测试和相应的代码。所以它远非完美。有时你必须给 AI 一点“当头棒喝”。我本想在开头提到这一点。人们谈论“氛围编程”，即你不检查代码。在我看来，还有另一种版本叫“愤怒编程”，就是当 AI 开始对你进行煤气灯操纵（gaslighting）
or doing something really stupid. The worst case is where it'll have failing tests and just gaslight you and tell you that, oh perfect, the tests are passing now, problem solved. And then you'll tell it, what are you talking about? You know that the tests are failing, I know that the tests are passing now, problem solved. And then you'll tell it, what are you talking about? You know that the tests are failing. I know that the tests are failing. Why are you telling me that they're not failing?
或者做一些非常愚蠢的事情时。最糟糕的情况是，测试失败了，它却对你进行煤气灯操纵，告诉你：“哦，太完美了，测试现在通过了，问题解决了。”然后你会对它说：“你在说什么？你知道测试失败了。”我明明知道测试失败了。为什么你要告诉我它们没失败？
And then it'll run them again. It shows you, you can see in like the little embedded terminal in cursor that it fails and it'll just say, perfect, they're passing. And it is immensely frustrating. It's more frustrating than any other thing I've experienced programming. So you know, vibe coding is a thing, rage coding is a thing, but there's this sweet spot right in the middle.
然后它会再次运行它们。它会展示给你看，你可以在 Cursor 的嵌入式终端里看到它失败了，但它还是会说：“完美，它们通过了。”这非常令人沮丧。这比我在编程中经历过的任何事情都更令人沮丧。所以你知道，“氛围编程”是一种现象，“愤怒编程”也是一种现象，但在这两者之间有一个最佳平衡点。
I call it guide coding. It's where you're basically, you're pair programming with an AI, you're not driving, the AI is driving and you just hold its hand. Sometimes it's just hitting home run after home run after home run and then every once in a while it'll do something stupid. Or maybe it's not even stupid, it just misunderstands what you want and you need to hold its hand, you need to guide it,
我称之为“引导式编程”。在这种模式下，你基本上是在与 AI 进行结对编程，你不是驾驶员，AI 才是，你只需要牵着它的手。有时它能接连不断地打出全垒打，但偶尔它也会犯傻。或者也许它并不傻，只是误解了你的意图，你需要牵着它的手，你需要引导它，
point it in the right direction and send it off. And sometimes that phase where you're guiding it, it'll last for 30 minutes, 40 minutes in order for you to guide it in the direction. But in the case where you port, you porting, you know, 1700 lines of unit tests is going to take like days, if not like a week, it's worth it to spend that 30 minutes, and in this case it didn't take 30 minutes, but there's been other cases where I've been trying to do something and it really doesn't understand.
给它指明正确的方向，然后让它去执行。有时引导它的阶段会持续 30 到 40 分钟，才能让它走上正轨。但在移植 1700 行单元测试的情况下，如果手动去做可能需要几天甚至一周，花这 30 分钟是值得的。虽然这次没花到 30 分钟，但也有其他情况，我试图做某事，而它真的不理解。
But then once I do figure out the magic incantation to get it to do exactly what I want, you know, take that incantation, throw it in a cursor rule, and then the next time you want to do something like that, you just invoke the cursor rule and say, hey, do this, follow the rule, and you're good to go. So that's my solo podcast, folks. It's probably, what, how long have I been recording for? 10 minutes, 15 minutes? It is so sunny out
但一旦我找到了让它完全按照我意图执行的“咒语”，我就把那段咒语放进 Cursor 的规则里，下次你想做类似的事情时，只需调用该规则，说：“嘿，照做，遵循这个规则”，你就搞定了。这就是我的单人播客，伙计们。大概，我录了多久了？10 分钟，15 分钟？外面阳光真好。
It says 13 minutes, so once this kits cleaned up little intro added it'll probably be around 15 minutes or so and We we do have a house finch has been recognized a poorly named bird in my opinion because they're beautiful they got pink heads and They're a beautiful bird, but they got a very boring name of house finch so they don't get the respect they deserve. If my fiance is listening to this she'll be chuckling now because I always I always tell her that you know the house sparrow and the house finch they got they got bad names. House sparrow one of the most resilient birds in the world. It's everywhere it's everywhere every country
显示是 13 分钟，所以等剪辑好加上简短的片头，大概会在 15 分钟左右。我们这里有一只家朱雀，在我看来这是一个命名很糟糕的鸟，因为它们很漂亮，头是粉红色的，它们是很美的鸟，但名字却叫“家朱雀”，非常无聊，所以它们没有得到应有的尊重。如果我的未婚妻在听这个，她现在肯定在偷笑，因为我总是告诉她，家麻雀和家朱雀的名字起得太差了。家麻雀是世界上最顽强的鸟类之一。它无处不在，每个国家
I've ever gone to. There's the House Sparrow kicking around. Anyways, there's vibe coding, there's rage coding, and there's guide coding. I implore you to give guide coding a try. 10x your productivity, 100x your productivity. This is the future, this is the future for software developers.
我去过的地方都有家麻雀在蹦跶。总之，有氛围编程，有愤怒编程，还有引导式编程。我恳请你们尝试一下引导式编程。让你的生产力提高 10 倍，100 倍。这就是未来，这就是软件开发者的未来。
For some of you, you're gonna be doing some gnarly template metaprogramming stuff, or constexpr metaprogramming stuff, or cutting edge reflection metaprogramming stuff. And guide coding isn't going to get you very far. But there is a huge set of tasks that guide coding with these LLMs are just amazing for.
对于你们中的一些人来说，你们可能会做一些棘手的模板元编程、constexpr 元编程或前沿的反射元编程。引导式编程可能帮不了你太多。但对于大量的任务来说，使用这些 LLM 进行引导式编程简直太棒了。
And it's only going to get better from here. So that's my pitch. We say goodbye to the American Crows, to the Canadian Geese, and to the House Finches. We did not get a appearance from the Mithred Parakeet. That's very unfortunate. And with that, I will say I hope you have a fantastic day and weekend if you're listening to this on Friday or Saturday or Sunday. Expect to hear from Ben and I next week where we will be chatting about
而且未来只会越来越好。这就是我的推销。我们要向美洲乌鸦、加拿大雁和家朱雀告别了。红额鹦哥没有出现，这非常遗憾。最后，如果你是在周五、周六或周日收听，祝你度过愉快的一天和周末。期待下周我和 Ben 的聊天，我们将讨论
a number of topics. Maybe we'll talk about the cost of commuting. One of my favorite combinators, the C-combinator, the Cardinal, aka Flip and Haskell, aka AKA commute in the array languages. I posted that tweet I don't know how many days or weeks ago at this point. It was a work of art called the cost of commuting. Maybe we'll chat about that. Maybe we'll chat about something else.
许多话题。也许我们会谈谈通勤的成本。我最喜欢的组合子之一，C-组合子，即 Cardinal，也就是 Haskell 中的 flip，或者数组语言中的 commute。我不知道在多少天或几周前发了那条推文。那是一件名为“通勤成本”的艺术品。也许我们会聊聊那个。也许我们会聊聊别的。
Until then, have a good one. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在那之前，祝一切顺利。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。